>> Tucker: EVER FEEL LIKE YOU
ARE THE LAST TO KNOW ABOUT
SOMETHING?
BILL AND HILLARY CLINTON MIGHT
MAKE YOU FEEL BETTER ABOUT THAT,
BILL AND HILLARY CLINTON ARE THE
ONLY TWO PEOPLE IN THE WORLD WHO
MIGHT NOT YET REALIZE THEY
AREN'T AS POPULAR AS THEY ONCE
WERE.
SALES HAVE BEEN LACKLUSTER TO
PUT IT CHARITABLY FOR THE
SPEAKING TOUR.
THOUSANDS OF ARENAS SEATS HAVE
BEEN COVERED UP IN TORONTO DUE
TO POOR SALES AND TICKET PRICES
THAT BEGAN IN THE HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS FAILED TO SINGLE DIGITS
BECAUSE NOBODY WANTED TO BUY
THEM.
AMERICA IS FINALLY, MERCIFULLY
GETTING OVER THE CLINTONS.
MARCUS, BEFORE WE ASSESS WHAT'S
OBVIOUS, WHICH IS, THEIR TIME IS
OVER, THE DEEPER QUESTION IS,
WHY DON'T THEY KNOW THAT AND
WHAT IS THE SPEAKING TOUR ABOUT?
>> I WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THAT IF
YOU DIDN'T KNOW BEFORE, LOOKING
OUT, AND ACTUALLY OVERESTIMATED
THE NUMBER OF SEATS.
IT WAS ACTUALLY 83.4% EMPTY, THE
ARENA IN TORONTO.
83.4% EMPTY.
I BELIEVE ACTUALLY THE LAST TIME
I GUESS TOASTED FOR YOU, THE
AUDIENCE WAS SUDDENLY 83.4%
EMPTY SO THESE THINGS CAN
HAPPEN.
>> Tucker: I SAW THE NUMBERS,
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
[LAUGHS]
>> WHEN YOU ARE THE PRESIDENT
AND, IT'S A GREAT FRANK SINATRA
LINE.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE 16.6%
SEATING CAPACITY IN TORONTO WAS
TELLING THE CLINTONS.
>> I HAVE TO SAY IN THEIR
DEFENSE THEY PLAYED THIS OUT A
LOT LONGER THAN I THOUGHT THEY
POSSIBLY COULD.
IT'S BEEN OVER 25 YEARS NOW.
I'VE NEVER FOUND THEM VERY
IMPRESSIVE BUT THAT MANAGED TO
GET INCREDIBLY RICH AND STAY
FAMOUS ALL THIS TIME, SO THEY
HAVE HAD A LONG RUN CONSIDERING
WHERE THEY STARTED.
BUT WHY DO THEY FEEL THE NEED TO
DO THIS?
THAT IS WHAT BAFFLES ME.
>> IT MAKES AN INTERESTING
CONTRAST WITH WHAT IS GOING ON
IN THE ROTUNDA RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
YOU CAN SAY WHAT YOU LIKE ABOUT
THE FIRST PRESIDENT BUSH BUT,
HIS POST-PRESIDENCY WAS A MODEL.
AND, HE SAID SOMETHING LIKE,
ABOUT BILL CLINTON, HE HAS A
HEATSEEKING GLAMOUR THAT LIVES
IN A PERMANENT HYPER PRESENT
TENSE AND DARES HIM TO JOIN THEM
THERE.
SHE ACTUALLY UNDERSTOOD THAT
THEY WERE ON A PERPETUAL HAMSTER
WHEEL, AND THEY ARE RAKING IN
BIG BOX FROM A NICHE MARKET.
AND, THAT'S $10 CANADIAN, WHICH
THANKS TO JUSTIN TRUDEAU IS
ABOUT A BUCK 79 AMERICAN RIGHT
NOW.
SO, THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT
A SAUDI PRINCE IS PREPARED TO
PAY, THAT TELLS YOU WHAT HAS
HAPPENED TO THE CLINTONS IN THE
REAL WORLD.
>> SO VERY QUICKLY, I'M JUST
SPECULATING HERE, BECAUSE MAYBE
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER.
THOSE EIGHT OR NINE GUYS WHO
DISMEMBERED KHASHOGGI, HOW MANY
WERE MEMBERS TO THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION.
DO YOU REMEMBER?
>> THE CLEVER THING ABOUT THEM,
THE WARRING FACTIONS IN THE
HOUSE OF SAUD WERE ALL BEING
DONE TO THE CLINTON FOUNDATION.
I'M NOT SAYING THERE ARE
DIFFERENT PRINCES BUT THEY WERE
ALL TRYING TO BUY OFF OF THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION AND THE GOOD
OLD DAYS.
PRICES SLASHED TO CLEAR ON THE